hey it's day two of next and wow what an
incredible day one right we had
announcements around data analytics
security sustainability and google
workspace and now we're on to day two to
give you a quick rundown of what to look
forward to we'll start the day with the
developer keynote you'll hear from the
leaders and developers who are bringing
our latest innovations to life google
cloud's vision for the top three
technology trends and how cloud
computing will evolve over the next
decade and don't miss the live q a
hosted by my fellow developer advocates
for everyone looking to get more out of
your cloud investment which let's face
it is everyone check out the app
modernization spotlight extend the value
of cloud investments anywhere with
google cloud our vp of is vp of app
modernization and director of product
management we'll be talking about how
we're extending our cloud services to
address more complex and unique use
cases from data center to the edge
you'll learn how to modernize your
people processes and applications to
take full advantage of the distributed
cloud from google
then join them for a live q a session to
get your questions answered
for security-minded leaders which once
again should be everyone here is your
chance to listen to our very own chief
information security officer and our vp
of security they'll discuss how to
engineer security directly into your
applications and platforms to eliminate
entire classes of threats without
friction they'll introduce the invisible
security vision and discuss the key
capabilities that can make it a reality
and yes we will have a live demo in this
one plus another live q a
channel two of the broadcast will
include a bunch of customer stories like
sabre braun institute meow wolf and papa
john's on how they're leveraging google
cloud security data platform vmware
engine and more don't forget we have
learning pathways to get hands-on check
out pathways for cloud infrastructure
data engineering and analytics
kubernetes hybrid and multi-cloud ml and
ai networking and security and more and
we also have a multitude of hands-on
labs for apogee vertex ai cloud sql and
more check out all the sessions with the
id hol enjoy day two of next and connect
on social by hashtagging google cloud
next and reach out to me at steph r
underscore wong